what's going on everybody and welcome to
part two of the updated Python 3 basics
series in this video I'd like to talk
about variables tuples strings and loops
all in one go let's get started so first
of all I'm gonna make a new directory
I'm just gonna call this tutorials then
I'm gonna open up sublime here and I'm
just gonna do a file save as we're gonna
save it to that tutorials here and I'm
just going to say tutorial to PI when I
try to save these in parts that way
later on when things we have actual
thicker code I can share it on Python
program and not net this one probably
you're not going to need the source code
for but eventually to you might want it
just in case you can't figure out what's
different so so first of all let's talk
about variables so a variable is just
anything that is a variables everything
in python is an object and a variable is
just a a word representation basically
of that object so for example we're
gonna have a variable called programming
underscore languages now variables have
a certain certain rules associated with
them you can't start a variable with a
number but you can have a number in a
variable like programming 1 equals some
sort of thing you can have underscores
and so on you can't have like a string
be a variable or something like that and
obviously since you can't start with a
number
you also can't have like an integer as a
variables you know a name but
programming language is a variable so to
define a variable use the assignment
operator not to be confused with a
double equals which is a question of you
know does this thing equal this other
thing more on that later but you use a
single equals and then we can pass
something like the following so the
reason why we're covering tuples now is
it just is going to make sense to cover
tuples now
I mostly actually just want to show you
guys how simple python is both to write
and read and this is why I fell in love
with Python to start so programming
languages equals Python Java C++ C I
think anybody can look at this and
understand okay I get it it's a list of
Python it's a list of programming
languages
unfortunately in Python it's actually
not a list and if you're ever curious to
find out what is this thing I'm dealing
with you can use a the built in the
built in type so you could say type
programming languages like this since
the sublime might be new to some people
that was a tab complete so programming
languages and then you can see it made
it a little suggestion I hit tab done so
that's how you can get what what is the
type of variable like what is the
objects type so if you wanted to output
that well we already saw a print before
so we could just print type and
languages so let's go ahead and run that
so again control B I just restarted this
machine so I'll pick Python eventually
we'll set that as a default but for now
class is tuple so this is actually a
tuple so generally you'll hear lists and
tuples later we will cover lists but for
now it's not necessary and the purpose
of this tutorial
my goal here is to just cover what we
need because this is really the way
you're gonna learn to program you're not
gonna learn you know this fundamental
thing on this fundamental thing that no
you're gonna try to solve a problem and
on your way of solving that problem
you're gonna learn new things along the
way use the things that you know and use
Google and a lovely lovely website
called Stack Overflow and maybe even
some reddit in there or you can come
into certain chats like ours is discord
GG / syntax all that kind of stuff you
that's how you actually learn so right
now we don't need lists I'm not gonna
cover lists my my goal here is to show
you guys how simple Python can be so we
know it to be a tuple
the reason why it's a tuple to define a
tuple either you could do something like
this where it's just a think um a thing
comma thing or object comma object comma
object or you could encase it in
parenthesis like this so if we do this
nothing has changed so just to prove
that to you let me just put these back
we run this again and you can see it's
still class tuple nothing has changed
but to make it pretty and easy to read
I'm gonna remove those and now let's
talk about a final thing a loop in this
case I'm gonna use a for loop just
because again it's gonna be a little
easier to read than a while loop at some
point we probably will cover a while
loop I just don't need it right now
so if we want to do like imagine if you
want to just dictate how you would he
would go over this you would say you
know for each of these let's you know
maybe out put them in some way so we
know print two outputs so it's you just
using natural language we would say you
know for each of the languages in
programming language print the language
correct or something like that so so
what you could say it's literally for
language and so language becomes this
little temporary variable here so for
language in programming language is :
and then enter because we're going to
start a new code block underneath this
for so anytime you've got you know the
definition of a function or a for loop a
while loop
later on we'll do some if statements
stuff like that if something is the case
: new line and then you'll see that the
editor just automatically tabbed it over
for me also let's talk about tabs really
quick I see that it has given me a silly
tab that's a mistake let me see if I can
fix that right away convert okay great
so if everybody's following along and no
matter what editor you're in let's make
this absolutely essential change
immediately so as I highlight this I can
see it's just one big line that means
it's a tab the problem with this is you
obviously don't want to just pound your
spacebar four times but a tab should
always be forced
and the reason why is as you upload this
maybe to github or share it with your
friend who uses a different editor they
might open it up and their settings
might be totally different from your
settings and then suddenly the the tabs
are the way that you sent them and then
they start adding things and then
suddenly they don't met mesh you've got
some tabs some spaces and it just goes
goes down very quickly so I'm just gonna
left click on this I do want it to be
for google likes too but most of the
world accepts for spaces so we'll keep
with four and then I'm gonna say convert
indentation to spaces so hopefully now
you'll see dot dot dot that's what you
want anyway for language in programming
languages let's go ahead and just print
the language control B to run it boom
we've iterated now over this we would
initially want to call this a list but
in programming terms it's actually a
tuple the differentiating factor of a
tuple is its immutable meaning you can't
change it you can add to it you're not
gonna remove from it so if it's a thing
that you intend to not be changed in
your program should you maybe
accidentally you know run something that
might affect it you can't do it whereas
a list can be things can be deleted and
popped and added or appended and so on
so anyways later on we will see some
slightly more tricky reasons why there's
a differentiation between these just for
now know that at any point you can
always do a type also since I wanted to
last I'm going to right click here and
pin to taskbar so just to really drive
it home again I know I brought it up
before but don't forget about the Python
3 Docs so Python 3 tuple hopefully one
of the top results will be talks and
Python 337 unfortunately Google is not
the best at indexing you know the newest
greatest language but that's okay
because tuples really haven't changed
much and you can probably just come up
here and edit this
so rather than three three let's try
three seven see if we get away with that
yes so you can see first of all we've
talked about lists but we haven't done
anything with lists but you can see
right here they've got just a ton of
things these are all the little methods
that you can use on a list again that
doesn't need to make any sense to you
right now we'll talk about that as it
comes up but here hopefully I'm hoping
they're gonna do a slightly more I'm
guessing at some point they go a little
more in-depth into what exactly tuples
are but it says okay it starts here so
so yeah you could definitely read up on
this learn more about tuples if you're a
little confused or you want to just
learn more or not if you don't really
care to learn any more than where we are
right now that's totally fine too
because we're gonna just try to use
Python to solve actual problems not try
to learn everything in the atmosphere
that is Python and all that so anyways I
think I'm gonna stop it here and in the
next tutorial we're gonna actually start
our overarching objective which will be
to make a simple text-based tic-tac-toe
game in Python which actually will
should let us cover pretty much all of
the principles of Python I think you
need before you can get out of the
basics and start doing things that
actually interest you so that's all for
now if you have questions comments
concerns whatever feel fruit is even
below you can also come join our discord
server that's you can just go to any old
browser and discord gg so lash cent X
should give you the invite you'll need
an account and all that but anyways yeah
you can come and join our server and we
have a help channel so if you're having
any problems come in there and ask for
help so anyways that's it for now
questions comments concerns whatever
feel free to leave them below if you
like the content give it a subscribe
thumbs up if you didn't like content
thumbs down and if you would be so kind
tell me why the thumbs down so that's it
for now I will see you guys in the next
video